des vitraux des milliers de vitraux
comme un sacerdoce Guill Lefèvre a dédié
sa vie à cet art qui se joue de la
lumière le maître verrier s'expose au
musée de villal à Saint-Gil Léo les
journées du patrimoine ont été
l'occasion pour le public de se rendre
dans son atelier représenté par cette
grande affiche qui accueille
l'exposition à défaut d'être chez gu qui
pourrait nous inviter c'est
effectivement symboliquement d'être
accueilli dans son atelier par cette
grande vue panoramique une exposition
consacrée à un maître verrier qui est un
voisin du du musée et qui a plus d'une
cinquantaine d'années de production de
vitro à la Réunion donc on a choisi
cette journée très populaire pour
finalement mettre en valeur le travail
aussi d'un d'un maître veiller artiste
très populaire et puis il y a les
différentes étape de la création le coup
de crayon le génie du verre qui a force
de patience est devenu un artisan avant
de se révéler artiste l'histoire
commence à Madagascar mais s'écrira
réellement à la Réunion j'ai rencontré
père
bén la pierre qui vire et il av un
atelier de
vitraille à Madagascar moi je suis na de
Madagascar
et il vit mais personne dessin maqu
vit il m' embché pour faire les dessins
maques mais pour faire des maques de vit
j'ai demandé à faire pour apprendre
toucher la matière parce que on peut pas
dessiner comme ça dans
l'abstrait et quand ils ont voulu vendre
leur leur atelier parce qu'ils s'en
allit j'ai racheté l'atelier faire
disparaître la transparence et révéler
la magie du lieu et des lumières qui
pénètrent si le maître verrier s'est
beaucoup donné aux édifices religieux il
a su aussi marquer de son empreunte des
bâtiments de toutes sortes comme en
témoigne cette carte de lîle où gu
Lefèvre a constitué un patrimoine
inestimableie il était important de
montrer qu'avitra effectivement ne peut
se comprendre aussi que par rapport à un
espace architecturé une exposition au
musée de villel jusqu'au 14 août
prochain mais surtout une petite
escapade dans la chapelle pointu avec
des œuvres qui même éclairé de manière
artificielle révèlent toute leur magie
et leur beauté pour prendre la dimension
du lieu et des création de Guy Lefèvre
un film mais aussi une musique celle de
bac jouée par Stéphanie ao un vrai
moment de
[Musique]
grâce c'est un enchantement les couleurs
sont tellement
fascinantes le film est hypnotique je
dirais c'est vraiment c'est un travail
que je connais déjà et la merilleuse
auourd'hui c'est très un hommage rendu
par le Conseil départemental qui à
travers cette exposition met dans la
lumière et en lumière l'homme et ses
uvres le Conseil départemental sachezle
que je représente est en effet très
attaché à toutes les forme d'art nous
avons fait le choix audacieux pour cette
exposition de mettre en valeur un
artiste qui contribue
aussiâ la réunionv qui travaillé à
Madagascar à la Réunion est aussi un
peintre un sculpteur h père ce touche à
tout de 92 ans nous révèle son histoire
à travers une exposition qui retrace son
parcours son travail ingrémenté de films
de photos réalisé en collaboration avec
Hervé Doris et Jean-Paul dupuie un
travail de l'ombre où se reflète la
lumière qui aujourd'hui enfin se pose
sur son
créateur
[Musique]